une église toujours à l'abandon trois
ans après avoir créé une association
pour sauver le patrimoine de sens
daniel jce elle et son mari mesure
pourtant le chemin parcouru les
grillages et autres objets qu'ils
n'avaient rien à faire ici ont bien été
évacuée par les services techniques
municipaux et la centaine de bénévoles
de l'association ont pu nettoyer les
sols mais cette église interdite au
public dans un tel état de délabrement
est pour eux un véritable gâchis
le mobilier est classé tout est classé
dans cette église
nous avons un orgue qui pourrait offrir
ce n'est pas du tout le même bord que la
cathédrale de sens mais où on pourrait
avoir des concerts différents ça ça
pourrait être aussi une classe d'orgue
bon il ya beaucoup de choses mais c'est
pas moi qui décide
moi je vois les potentialités de cette
église vitraux du 15e siècle statue
sculptée
l'église est l'une des plus riches et
des plus fournis de sens classé monument
historique
ce joyau du 13ème siècle et pourtant
fermé depuis 50 ans résultat nos billets
et statuaires sont longtemps restés à
l'abandon propriétaire de l'église la
ville a bien conscience de cette
situation mais sans ce compte 36 autres
monuments classés ou inscrits à
entretenir et faute de moyens
la commune doit aussi faire des choix
ici on a quand même fait permis de faire
du nettoyage c'est déjà bien qu'on va
poursuivre mais l'essentiel est pour
nous ailleurs pour l'instant ça veut pas
dire c'est pas important que ça fait
partie de notre patrimoine et qu'on se
doit de le réhabiliter
mais vont les choses il ya un ordre des
priorités
la ville et l'association se sont
rencontrés il ya peu avec le retour des
beaux jours
une nouvelle opération de nettoyage est
prévue à l'intérieur de l'église